[Music]
all right guys
bang bang i've got a very special guest
uh
probably one of the earliest internet
entrepreneurs kevin rose
uh is with us um we are recording this
as part of the stacks conference which
is uh block stacks
uh a virtual event and so there's been a
ton of great speakers
um and lots of great information uh so
highly recommend you go and check out
the rest of them but kevin thank you so
much for taking the time to do this
you know i'm so glad to be here i know
we've traded emails over the last like
six months or so or three months
whatever it is and
couldn't find a time and it's awesome as
a as a listener of your show it's cool
to actually be on so thanks for having
me
so i have to say that um there was a
moment
where all of a sudden my phone started
blowing up
uh middle of last year and um
yeah i started looking and everyone was
like tim ferriss and kevin
are talking about the chamoth episode uh
of the podcast and i was like wait what
is going on
and so i went and i listened to the
episode and i guess you had listened to
chamoth palpatia right in like the heart
of
uh the pandemic and the economic crisis
pretty much just say what he meant
and he really kind of went off and so it
was cool to kind of hear your thoughts
about one of the episodes
uh but maybe let's start with your
background um
you know you've worked on so many
important pieces of what i kind of
consider
that the internet um you know economy
maybe just like how do you describe
where you grew up and how you got into
the technology industry
yeah well i of all places i grew up in
las vegas nevada like i was
moved out there my dad was in finance um
he worked for a company called principal
financial group and like they had a good
paying job
and it was like a chance for us to like
have a little bit more money we were
like standard kind of middle class
family and so
um he moved out there uh that put me in
the middle of all things las vegas
did not really enjoy that but i got into
tech and computers out there and
desperately wanted to
figure out a way to get to the bay area
because i just had been reading about
how everything was going on
you know especially in 99 2000 and so
i said well i got to get to sf um
figured out a way to get kind of a
low-level job
working in san francisco moved out there
uh
fell in love with the city eventually it
took me a little while to to love that
city
um and then yeah started my own thing in
2004
when uh the kind of web 2.0 was just
getting started
and i uh launched the first social news
website called dig
and and so that happened in uh in
late 2004 and kind of to my surprise
just
people like to vote on articles and tell
you which ones are the best and
have a say and all this stuff was
relatively new because there really
wasn't
a way um to do this stuff in a real-time
fashion that type of technology was just
coming online so like
a great example is you know when we um
if you were to dig some something back
then or or eventually later
you know about a year later when
facebook added likes um or you
upload something on reddit people used
to forget it would actually have to take
you to another page
like when we first launched dig you
would have to say like dig something
would take you to another page and say
thank you for your dig because there was
no way to do it in
line and so when they came out with
asynchronous javascript to make that
happen
you could actually click something and
see the page refresh with the number
and as silly as it sounds today that was
like bleeding edge back then
and so that's uh that's kind of some of
those early
um kind of new versions of uh ways to
manipulate javascript was what led us to
creating some of this real-time voting
and and it was right place right time uh
lots of luck and it just took off from
there how did it feel
to have built something that uh really
became part of
people's habits on the internet right
kind of the the early users of
um digg ended up a lot of them going to
be very successful
uh technology entrepreneurs as well but
just i'm sure people would tell you all
the time like oh i use dig every day or
uh literally you know i remember using
digs so much
how does that feel today or even back
then
you know it's i think that any time
you can have a small little impact on
the internet and change
a just a little tiny piece of it is it's
a beautiful thing and
i i would say the the biggest one was
probably when drew
the founder of dropbox came up to me and
was like
uh we launched on dick and that's what
really blew us up on that first day and
he's just like thank me for that and i'm
like wow you like you
created dropbox like thank you like
that's awesome
so it was it was a cool it was it was um
it was such a small community back then
though like when web 2.0
happened it wasn't like you know in
today with all the money in in the
valley and all the startups and
you know there being thousands and
thousands of different startups kind of
all competing for the same eyeballs and
um just a flood of money back then
it was a handful of folks so like you
knew the twitter folks and
uh you know zuckerberg was really
curious about diggs before he added like
so he came over to my office and like
just sat on the floor with his slippers
and like talked about like how it worked
and like there was like all those early
days but
no one was thinking it would be this big
it was like it was just like
well how can we make our websites better
like there was no mobile's like how can
we just make our websites better or what
features can we add to
attract more users so um to watch and
see how you know twitter and facebook
and and some of the other bigger
platforms reddit and others have changed
the world it's just it's so cool
it was it was a great time and lots of
mistakes made i was in my early 20s
uh definitely had no idea how to manage
people no idea how to
uh properly um
hire or fire or prune or any of the
things that a good
founder and ceo should do it just we it
was i was just so immature
so um you know i look back on those days
and just
see a lot of mistakes but really it's
just lessons learned you know it's just
it i used to beat myself up about them
now i just consider them you know really
valuable lessons that i wouldn't make
today and ones that i had to go through
yeah and obviously being a little bit
older having more experience it
helps in in the hindsight there talk a
little bit about the evolution of
content moderation you know as you built
that kind of first sight
and you had to break a lot of ground and
kind of figure
things out i don't know how many really
you know examples you could pull from
you know even zuck had you to go and
talk about likes and digs and all of
that
how have you seen some of the decisions
that you guys made early on
evolve into today's world and how do you
think about content moderation on the
internet today
yeah it's funny i was talking to a
friend of mine who
who was kind of our head of content
moderation at dig and
he's now been at reddit for seven or
eight years something like that now and
and and does a bunch of moderation over
there um
and just seeing the and hearing about
this the
the better just the technology that they
have today on the machine learning side
and
and the things that they're doing to
identify spam early on that we didn't
have back then
but you know i look at what's happening
on twitter
with the issues that they've had around
moderation
and um i really feel
it's when you've been behind the scenes
and you see what happens you realize
the uh just how crazy it is and the
general public typically doesn't see
this type of
of of thing and so like for example um
and i'm sure reddit has to deal a lot
with this is like when you want
something
on the front page of reddit and you want
to get it because you know there's you
know millions of eyeballs there right if
you can get a story on the front page of
reddit that's worth a lot of
money right so spammers are going to go
and try
every single angle of attack to try and
get something on that front page
and oftentimes what happens is they'll
go in
attack something and then claim foul
play and say
you are you know suppressing the story
this is false moderation and from
just a standard consumer on the site
you're like yeah this this thing had
thousands of votes why is it not on the
front page but what you don't see
is behind the scenes 80 of those votes
came in a a not a natural way but a way
that
they've determined to be fraudulent so
that can be people going directly to the
permalink site
um without actually naturally
discovering it through the kind of
upcoming section or
any other page it could be a bunch of
new accounts all voting on the same
thing could be a bunch of accounts from
the same ip address
um it can be a bunch of accounts all are
votes all happening within a very short
time window there's just like a thousand
different things to look at
and and and from uh just a consumer
looking at the total number of votes you
would say
well something is wrong like reddit's
suppressing this or digital suppressing
this or whatever it may be
but in reality there's just a whole mess
that that you have to and you can't come
out and say and call them out right
publicly that's just not a thing you do
so it just turns into you know
scandal or quote unquote deep state
trying to keep us down or whatever it
may be
behind the scenes and in reality there's
a bunch of shady stuff going on
and so when i see that happening at
twitter and other places and just
you know when we added like you know
messaging or the ability to communicate
behind the scenes and you see people
all getting together in big groups like
trying to all
zero in on an article to try and promote
and uh
it is it it makes me feel very fortunate
that i'm no longer
in that game because it's messy it is
really messy
it also feels like um there's this
constant
uh healthy tension right if you're that
person who wants
traffic you want to do everything you
can to increase the probability of
getting
traffic getting you know better
placement getting kind of up in the
rankings on the various sites uh but at
the same time
people uh don't want you to do that who
run the site and so
you know there's always the trick of
like i love when a startup will email me
and say you know product
hey don't click on this link but go to
the product website you know scroll down
we're ranked about you know 30th right
now uh you'll find us around there and
then upload us
and so it's funny to kind of see um
the constant cat and mouse game i think
uh
it but what that does lead to though is
you've mentioned a couple times like
almost malicious actors right or kind of
bad actors
um and so how did you guys previously
deal with this
at digg or maybe for the other companies
you've invested in and then
now we're seeing more of what i'll call
just like deep platforming or kind of
completely taking people
offline um is that not really a new
thing and that's been going on for a
long time it just maybe people didn't
talk about it as much didn't have as
much tension
or is it something that maybe is a more
aggressive response to kind of the
ratcheting up of activity from
users like how do you just think about
the evolution of that
uh yeah it's tough because you have to
put
users like there's there's there's not
one universal policy that'll just apply
and work well
to everyone so there's different
intentions behind
each of these different types of you
know quote unquote fraud or manipulation
of the system
and so sometimes we had like to your
point like there are people that come in
that have great articles
that just want to get more exposure and
so they tell their friends go try and
find this organically and vote it up and
blah blah and that
there's not really a lot of harm in that
there's confusion in that like i
remember one time when cnet
they had probably 75 of their employees
go and sign up for dig accounts and all
dig the same article
and they were pissed that it didn't make
the front page and i i'm looking at the
data
and it's all like cnet email addresses
and it was
all employees and they'd all created
accounts within the last 20 minutes
and i'm like you guys don't understand
like there's a whole karma system that
you can't see behind the scenes that is
attributed to each one of these accounts
we know these are new accounts
and we're not going to give them the
same weight as we say would someone
that's been on the site for three years
so they just couldn't understand why
their content wasn't making the home
page and so
it's frustrating for those people
especially when they're they believe
they're trying to do something good in
this case it wasn't it wasn't a bad act
it was like the
legitimate article they were just trying
to give it a little extra love now
there's there's
the other side of things where you know
you have a spammer you know you have
someone that is really trying to promote
um paid content or content that is just
like you know
the typical spam that you would see in
your inbox you know stuff like that so
we would do all different types of
things including we had a system
where you could set a flag on someone's
account or a series of accounts or
hundreds of accounts
and tell them they were called like
silent accounts and what that meant
is they could come and dig all day long
and they would actually see the numbers
go up
but if they logged out or anyone else
looked at them the numbers would ever
never go up so they actually were just
spinning their wheels they thought they
were like actually positively voting on
something
and so this was great because the second
you bam the spammer
they see that they've been banned and
they go and create another dozen or five
dozen or whatever it mean
you know new accounts and so this just
kept them believing that they were doing
something when in reality they weren't
so
there's just so many different tactics
and then of course the kind of like
actual physical banning of people like
we we did that by the
you know we probably i don't know how
many we had by the
time that i left gig but it was in the
hundreds of thousands if not
over a million accounts banned you know
it's it's just
um there are certain times where
people are so malicious that you you
just can't they can no longer be
active on your platform and you have to
do everything you can like i mean hate
speech
um things of threats like i had to have
when i was doing a live podcast one time
uh 24 hours before we were gonna go live
we had a bunch of emails that were sent
saying that someone was gonna bring a
gun and shoot me and kill me at the live
podcast
and so we had to hire um personal
security to come out and
like frisk everyone checked their bags
when they came in for the live show
um and we talked to the fbi back then
and it was just
you know it's stuff like that where you
you got to be careful
yeah and it feels like uh there's a
difference between
if i am maliciously like uh you're
trying to vote things up and almost uh
not creating content but more so trying
to manipulate it
that's very different than if i'm the
one who's actually creating the content
i'm saying things that are
malicious hurtful you know kind of
violent whatever
and both from a moderation standpoint is
it different but also
uh there seems to be more sensitivity
and uh much more anger around i'm being
silenced
versus i can't take an action on a site
right like to me it's the
the silencing component seems to be
where all of the focus goes but really
what you're saying is hey for
you know two decades there's been all
sorts of things that these platforms
have been doing
um not necessarily in a bad way like
they're trying to make the experience
and the product as good as possible for
the people who are there for the right
reasons
that's right but the other thing too is
you have to realize is
this is not a freedom of speech issue
it's not
the government saying i can't say
something which is what freedom of
speech is
it's essentially a private company
that's offering a free service
to its users saying we don't want you in
our store anymore we don't want you
in our house anymore this is our private
company
and it's completely within their rights
to say that i mean that's that's
the beautiful thing about america like
we can say i built this service i don't
you're not
um i have a series a set of rules and
guidelines
you're not adhering to those and so you
are no longer welcome here
and i i i'm not directing that at trump
i'm directing that
i mean this is all users like that's the
beautiful thing about
these private businesses is they have
the ability to do that i i think it's
it's a thing that we need to protect
like it's very important it's
it's it's people i think the vast
majority it's sad to see on twitter that
a lot of people
believe freedom of speech means i
freedom of platform like i
if i'm on facebook i get to stay on
facebook no matter what i say or i get
to stay on twitter no matter what i say
and that's not the case they're giving
you a free service you're not even
paying for it and you just expect to be
able to spout whatever you want and they
have to
have to keep you on it's not the law
that's not the way it works and there's
just a lot of confusion there
so and i tend to agree with you right
that like look these are private
companies
uh and they're basically reminding us
that they're private companies and they
can do this right and i think people may
have
forgotten that or be confused um does
the
analysis change or kind of how do you
see the difference when
um you know let's say it is uh a random
you know 25 year old person in the
united states who
uh isn't well known by any you know
measure
uh and it's just kind of going about
their day uh i want to interact with
family and friends let's say versus the
president of the united states right or
some other
uh well-known figure especially if it's
politically related
uh either in the united states or
internationally like how do you think
about
almost um the uh the magnitude of the
person and the weight of the words and
how that plays into some of these
decisions because it feels like
that is a nuance that might not be
discussed as much
um in the press but the technology
companies seem to put a lot of
importance on that specific component
yeah
it's it's i don't know this is above my
pay grade it's it's difficult
in that i feel if it's hard to say what
you would do if you were sitting in that
position right like i feel
there's importance that that you want to
allow
the information to get out there and
it's going to get out there one way or
another whether it be
like if someone gets cut off on twitter
they can go to their private email
newsletter they can go to their website
they can go to a thousand of their
outlets
most of them have large followings
people that they can text because they
signed up for some type of text me at
this number to join our group you know
so there's a lot of ways to spread this
information
um so it's it's really
i i think that twitter is it's tough
because
on one hand they realize that
and i also think that if if you cut off
the thing that i'm most concerned about
that i'm scared about is that
when you kick people off of a platform
they will find an alternative
and we are very close technology wise
to completely decentralized systems
that will allow these to exist no matter
what is said now they may not be in the
app store because
obviously google facebook um
samsung others they control the content
in their app stores but the content
could live in a decentralized fashion
that cannot be censored
um and that's a lot of people working
towards building these systems and
there's a lot of good
in those types of systems but i can
imagine there being in the next five
years
you know a twitter like service that you
just can't take down and you can't
delete and everything stays up there
forever
it's stored information is stored on the
blockchain and it just becomes a
free-for-all
for misinformation for spreading of hate
speech for a lot of a lot of really bad
things so
it's um you know and then what happens
do we try and break
block that or break it at the ip level
like do we try and actually shut down
uh you know our block when the
the traffic is encrypted there's not
really a way to do that you know so
there's
it's it's uh it's a whole can of worms
you know it's there's no
easy elegant solution here yeah and so
you actually uh started to touch on what
my last question was going to be just
around
it feels like uh the more and more that
the
centralized companies which by the way
has been the default it has led to
incredible value creation
and it's probably been i think pretty
undeniably the best solution so far
um in terms of building a centralized
corporation and that owns a product and
monetizing it
the more that they kind of highlight or
leverage the power and control that they
have
and again in a positive way the way that
they think is the best way to run their
service and they're
legally entitled to do it i do think
that there's more and more interest in
the youngest generations
in decentralization right and i think
you're right in highlighting like
hey that's not necessarily just a
positive solution like there are
downsides to it how likely is it do you
think that we get
what i'll call kind of mainstream
decentralized you know whether it's a
social network a mobile app
a website um and really the perspective
i've had on this is like i don't know
maybe five years ago
definitely when you started digg uh if
anyone said hey i'm gonna build a
decentralized website
they kind of got put into the like oh
you're just paranoid category
like why does it need to be you know
decentralized that seems to be
changing now um and so is it something
where it's like yeah actually maybe the
default is going to switch to
decentralization
or is this just hey we're human and
we're having a short-term kind of uh
overreaction
and like the truth somewhere in between
we have like coexistence between
centralized and decentralized systems
moving forward
yeah i think there's gonna be a little
bit of a co-existence between the two
like i
even today like if you if you're running
say something like the brave browser
which is you know like a chrome based
browser that has privacy first
um you go to the new york times it
offers you with one click to open it and
tour and have it be a completely
anonymous
now granted it's gonna be much slower
right like decentralized systems in
general
they don't have the crazy edge servers
and caching and all the other
stuff that a centralized service will
bring you that give you
you know crazy response times that load
the page in a
quarter of a second so uh some of these
systems are going to be
certainly slower i certainly believe
that um
you're going to have a lot of the
types of users that were banned that are
spreading certain types of information
whether it be the misinformation or
um uh you know some of the evil hate
groups and things like that they will
move to decentralized solutions like
because there is not going to be any
other home for them
and the tools moderation tools will get
better and better over time right
so if you know today you can post
something about the kkk and it'll last
for three hours on twitter
you're you're still pretty happy with
that but uh
you know as a if that their moderation
tools get better and that stuff is
removed instantly
then you're going to move to something
else so it's
it's going to be a question of whether
or not anyone
like do people put this in the bucket of
kind of the dark web
where only a certain subset of people
that know what they're doing and know
what they're getting into go to
or will there be any legitimate users on
there that kind of somewhat make the
platform seem
like it is a place to hang out for an
everyday user if that makes sense
yeah absolutely and i mean we would be
uh
doing everyone a disservice if we didn't
talk about uh bitcoin being kind of this
you know really probably the most
valuable uh best example of these
decentralized services that seems to not
only be working but also getting
mainstream adoption talk just a little
bit in closing about kind of your
thoughts around bitcoin
um and and maybe the importance of that
system in the world and kind of how
entrepreneurs are seeing that as an
example of what they
can aspire to build yeah i mean bitcoin
has been
a fun one to watch and i think we're
finally getting
to the place where a few things are
coming together that are giving it kind
of renewed life
um not very new life it's always been
alive it's just the question of
adoption and so i i think there's a few
different levers that are that are
happening all the same time one
it's just age is a big deal like every
week every month every year that goes by
where this thing has been
hammered on and pounded on by everyone
and
uh there is increased confidence in
the technical feasibility although
that's been there for from the get-go
for
for the geeks uh the average consumer
and institutional buyers get a lot more
comfortable with placing bets
in that in that arena so you'll see more
funds on the
institutional side moving in there as
the the confidence in the
in the protocol grows on the
more consumer side we're just seeing uh
the on-ramp and and ability to get into
bitcoin just being so easy i mean
the fact that you can go into paypal now
and just buy it directly in your paypal
account
is insane i mean and that's that was
that was
square cash and everyone's like oh yeah
i've used square cash maybe i'll use
that as my and then it was
um you know robin hood and a few others
but now
the big big players not the square isn't
a big player but you know paypal is much
larger
um they're going to get in the arena and
say there's money to be made here
let's go ahead and offer this to our
consumers i would imagine
we start seeing that uh it wouldn't
surprise me if major banks start doing
the same thing
and when that happens it's just really
gonna unlock a lot of
demand and i think that things continue
to go higher
that coupled with the fact that the
united states is just printing money
um a lot of other governments are way
worse than we are here in the states and
so
it gives us something that we can all
point to as like a universal
store of value i think that becomes more
and more true over time
in terms of the actual utility of it day
to day am i buying bread with bitcoin no
and i don't think that's going to happen
anytime soon but you know
the same thing you're not buying bread
with your gold etf either
so it's it's i i'm i'm pretty excited
about the future of bitcoin
uh you know it's being extended blocks
texting some interesting stuff to extend
it as well
um create smart contracts on top of it
things of that nature uh
make it more ethereum like i mean these
are the the industry is maturing quite a
bit
so it's um it's pretty exciting and i
think that
if you're this is the the crazy uncle
question i always get at thanksgiving
and now for zoom thanksgivings is like
should i buy bitcoin you know
and the the answer is
is really simple if you're trying to
flip it and you just want to double your
money or triple your money
like stop stop like you're putting in
too much then because it means a lot to
you
and so you're better off putting in less
money and forgetting about it for 10 15
20 years
then you are putting in something where
you just want to see it double so
you know for me that means two percent
of my overall
portfolio maybe three percent of all of
my different assets across
all asset classes and if you can just
put it in there and forget about it for
the next 10 15
20 years and then figure out has this
has this grown to a point where it's 10
15 20
of my overall assets and if so consider
doing some you know
moving around and pruning to make sure
that you you have the allocation targets
that you're looking to hit so
um but i am i'm uh obviously if you
are a brand new country getting started
today you're not going out and buying
printers and printing money like digital
currency is here to stay there's no
doubt about that it's been the case for
a long time now
and um you know with bitcoin you
obviously have have the leader and i
can't see that changing anytime soon so
um i'm i'm i'm a fan and and will
continue to continue to be a fan because
it's uh
it's just the future it's like it's like
electric vehicles it's so obvious
i i could not agree more it's also uh
funny to me because uh if you talk to
young kids
um you know people say oh that is the
um you know kind of robin hood
generation portfolio right it's like
tesla and bitcoin and it's like well
yeah because they understand maybe some
trends that you know
older folks aren't uh quite aware of yet
so we'll see how
how it all plays out but i tend to think
that your perspective is uh is pretty
accurate and spot on
um where can we send people to find you
on the internet and find out more about
your work at
true yeah so trueventures.com is um
is is where i invest day to day so i'm a
partner over there
um we invest in the very early seed
stage series a
um and that's uh that's kind of my day
to day i focus on consumer internet
cryptocurrency
and a few other things i also do a
newsletter that i send out
probably every other month or so and you
can just find that at kevinrose.com
and it's just all of the the crazy
things that i'm investigating new
technologies things i'm excited about
books i'm reading
um and so it's a it is a kind of crazy
hodgepodge of
all different types of links and fun
stuff but i i i
yeah i try not to spam people so every
couple months is about the right cadence
for me
uh and you can sign up for that over at
cameras.com
awesome listen thank you so much for
doing this uh you know as i start off
saying uh you literally built some of
the uh the coolest companies on the
internet
and uh i've been a huge part of a lot of
people uh kind of following your
footsteps so
uh you know one congratulations on all
the success and two thank you so much
for joining us today
oh dude it's my pleasure keep doing the
great shows because i will i will keep
listening you are
you're definitely one of my default
podcasts so thank you for that